hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty science
chemistry phd skin care
nerd and sunscreen obsessee
one of the big misconceptions is
how sunscreens work in particular
chemical versus physical sunscreens i've
debunked this a whole bunch of times before
and i have a video talking about the more
technical details behind how both chemical
and physical sunscreens absorb uv but then i
realized i could actually test this in real life
and maybe it'll be a little bit more convincing
if you like this sort of nerdy beauty
content click the like the subscribe and the
nerdification bell so you don't miss any videos
so like i said before both chemical
and physical sunscreens mostly work
by taking uv and converting it to a harmless
amount of heat physical sunscreens also scatter
about five percent of the incoming uv the
sun's energy is also about 53% infrared
which converts heat directly on our skin
and only about three to seven percent is uv
so if most of that tiny amount of uv is
converted to heat and there's only a small
amount of difference in that tiny amount of uv
there really shouldn't be much of a difference
but some people have questioned
whether that tiny tiny amount of heat
is enough to make a difference so i
decided to test out what happens in reality
so conveniently i found out that my boss
alex who is a former optics professor
actually owns an infrared camera this takes photos
that show things at different temperatures as
different colors and you can see down to about
a one degree celsius difference so i convinced
him to help me do some measurements with sunscreen
to see if we could see any interesting differences
so we took a bunch of different sunscreens
to a garden in sydney during spring
the first thing we noticed when we started looking
through the camera is that things that are made of
different materials and whether or not they're
in the sun makes a massive difference a brown
table in the sun was 65 degrees the stone in
the shade was 17 degrees you can see the color
scale on the side ignore the temperature in the
middle that's not always accurate we wrote down
the actual temperature numbers the next thing i
noticed was that things that i didn't think would
make a difference actually made a pretty big
difference so for example my arm near my elbow
was hotter than my arm near my wrist
that's because things that are closer
to the center of your body are warmer because
it's getting more warmth from things like blood
i actually had a whole bunch of sunscreens
both chemical and physical on my arm here
and you can't see any temperature differences but
you can see the difference between the top of my
arm and the bottom of my arm next i put a big
black texta mark on my arm to see if it would
make a difference we all know that black things
like to absorb lots of visible light from the sun
and heat up and there is a lot of visible light
in sunlight so we thought this would be a really
good test to see what a thin film of something
that absorbs light and produces heat really well
would look like on the skin but again there just
wasn't much of a difference i'm pointing at the
mark in these photos and if you squint you can
just see it but this does make sense humans are
about two-thirds water water is special because
it has a really high specific heat capacity
that means it can absorb lots of heat
energy without itself heating up very much
so basically your body is a huge heat sink a thin
film of something producing heat isn't producing
very much heat your body can easily absorb
that and handle that without itself heating up
so we decided to get rid of the heat sink and
see if we could see any differences without it
we applied two of the sunscreens
one chemical one physical onto
a thin piece of plastic well i applied
them while alex took random photos
at the start the chemical sunscreen was actually
four degrees colder we figured it was because the
sunscreens were still drying and so ethanol was
evaporating from that ethanol when it evaporates
cools down something significantly we tried
again 10 minutes later after everything dried
and we found that the physical sunscreen was one
degree colder but then we rotated the film by 180
degrees and we found that the chemical sunscreen
was one degree colder so it seems like the angle
of the film and the angle of the sun makes a
bigger difference than the type of sunscreen
so the plastic film i liberated from a nearby
construction site was actually red and white
so we decided to just look at that through the
camera the red part of the tape was actually
six degrees hotter than the white part and
so it seems like the color that something is
makes a much bigger difference than
whether a sunscreen is chemical or physical
for the final test i liberated a napkin
from a nearby restaurant and i blobbed
on nine different sunscreens i had chemical
sunscreens physical sunscreens combo sunscreens
and even one that claimed to have
ir protection and cooling effects
again we waited 10 minutes for everything to dry
and then we looked through the ir camera the first
thing we noticed was that the tinted sunscreens
were hotter than the white ones with the rest
of the sunscreens there wasn't really much of
a pattern between which ones are hot and cooler
in terms of whether they were physical or
chemical i was particularly disappointed
with the infrared one i really expected that
to have some sort of noticeable difference
so these results make sense based on the mechanism
of how chemical and physical sunscreens work and
the law of conservation of energy there shouldn't
really be much heat produced at all and only the
tiniest difference between chemical and physical
sunscreens and given how watery human bodies work
any heat that is produced should be dissipated
really really quickly it just spreads into the
rest of your body there is a lot more visible
light in sunlight than there is uv there
can be more than 10 times as much so it isn't
surprising that things that absorb visible light
heat up a lot more than things that absorb uv so
this is things like tinted sunscreens and red tape
but even then when you do put it on your skin
because of that heatsink effect there just isn't
much of a difference there was a much bigger
difference between the two parts of my arm than
with the black marker and no black marker so the
difference in heat between chemical and physical
sunscreens is insignificant there are other
reasons to pick chemical over physical or physical
over chemical but the amount of heat produced
just shouldn't factor into your decision making
after we did all this i actually found a paper
where some physicists calculated how much a
titanium dioxide sunscreen would heat up your skin
they calculated 0.2 degrees celsius so i hope that
was a convincing demonstration and hopefully that
does kill this myth a bit more let me know what
you think were you surprised by these results
i was actually quite surprised i was actually
hoping that we would see something interesting
there would be some sort of a difference but
i guess science works let me know if you have
any other topic suggestions in the comments below
click the like and the subscribe if you
like my videos you can also check me out on
instagram at lab muffin beauty science and my blog
labmuffin.com see you next time to nerd out more